اا ابتداء من عام تقريبا اييه 67 بدا
النشاط الفعلي الحركي في قطاعات التعليم
في المدارس كانت الاساس او الخطه او
البدايه في التوغل او الهدف وقطاع التعليم
الاساسي الهدف هو قطاع التعليم المدارس
المدارس
[موسيقى]
السياسيه والعسكريه
وهنا بدات الانطلاقه
لكن بعد ذلك كما قلت توسعت ودخلت الى
قطاعات مختلفه وكان الاهتمام ربما كما قلت
اساسا في قطاع الثالث
لتوغل هذه الجماعات في قطاع التعليم الى
اي حد
اصبحوا متنفذين او متوغلين او متحكمين في
المؤسسه التعليميه في السعوديه
درجه كبيره جدا طبعا في البدايه كانت
بدايه ضعيفه
لا يعني ما كان المجتمع همم معتاد على همم
العمل الحركي النشاطات الحركيه كانت غريبه
يعني في المدارس وفي همم لكنهم شيئا فشيئا
همم استثمر همم النشاط اللاصفي في همم
المدارس
والجمعيات كان جمعيه الكشافه جواله في
الجامعات همم جمعيات التوعيه الاسلاميه
الاذاعه المدرسيه المسرح كل شيء بداوا
يستفيدوا منها ومن خلالها يوجهون
ويستقبون في نفس الوقت همم الطلاب الى همم
جماعاتهم بمخ التنظيمات التي كانت تلعب في
الساحه في ذلك الوقت
حجم تاثيرهم الى اي مدى وصل برايك في
التعليم يعني في ذلك الوقت او ان ان ذلك
الوقت هم بعد ذلك ما هي النتائج تاثير
بالذات في فتره نهايه السبعينات
والثمانينات والتسعينيات بكاملها كان
تاثير واكتساح قوي لهم في القطاع التاليه
مش ملامح هذا التاثير يعني اللي ظهرت على
ارض الواقع برايه الملامح ما رايناه من
همم فكر التطرف فكر التشدد طبعا انا افرق
بين التطرف والتشدد ولكن هذا موجود وشبينه
مش بينهم الفرق التطرف همم يعني يكون
نتيجه لعمل حزبي منظم يصل بالفرد او
التابع لهذه الجماعه الى همم اعمال اقوال
او اعمال همم متطرفه او ارهابيه التشدد لا
التشدد قد يكون في مسائل دينيه معينه مساء
الفل مساء الكذا وليس بالضروره ان يكون
المتشدد همم تابع لايدلوجيه معينه او الى
تنظيم معين او الى حزم معين هذا الفرق
بينهما همم بلا شك انهم همم اكتسحوا واثر
على المجتمع والنتيجه ما راينا خلال فتره
التسعينات من الافكار التصرف التي اليها
في قضايا التفجير وقضايا التكفير
خروج على الدوله وعلى النظام همم سواء في
المملكه او في غيرها يعني